if you're not in the game you can't win
okay if you're not in the game you can't
win i love it figure out
how do you stay in the game despite
everything despite whatever is thrown at
you
you need to figure out
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders how are you
very good michael thank you for having
me here of course you're good look at
this view that you're talking from where
are you now
i am now from my home office this is
coffee time we are all shattering the
place
well it's a beautiful beautiful home
office but the view
the view is from mount rose in tow and
that's where i was two weeks ago
climbing with my bike by
climbing with your what bike bike
i didn't know you can climb with a bike
with a motorcycle
and when you have a mount clothes over
there in town you basically walk out and
climb work hard play hard guy
we have so much to talk about because
you know the most fascinating thing that
that asks you you know in preparation
for this i asked a simple question
i want to talk about you know the things
you're passionate about and your
different experiences and i listed like
seven things we could talk about
because you were the chief strategy
officer at blackberry
and you sold the company for 300 million
dollars to blackberry and hbs
and so on and you mentioned you know in
the adsense of it you're an entrepreneur
and that is what that is your true
passion beyond you know
the common the combination of all these
specific things guy what does it mean to
you that that you're an entrepreneur
you've been an entrepreneur for quite
some time so you probably have some good
inner understanding of what it means to
you that's a great question michael so
entrepreneur is really at the essence
it's it's it's in the art
it's about a an impeccable desire to
create something
that makes an impact it's about shaping
it the way you believe it should be
shaped
and it's really being a having the
passion to walk with dedicated and
brilliant people
these are for me the three things that
really make or drive me
and motivates me in the entrepreneurial
world it's create something make an
impact
shape it and work with amazing people
and you get that and you get that and
you can should make that happen
in this kind of when when did you become
an entrepreneur what was your turning
point was it after business school
before business school
in high school okay
uh so my first entrepreneurial venture
quote unquote
was actually almost a non-profit and
i i was in high school in farsaba
and there was a
boarding school over there for very
talented kids that come from a bit of a
more difficult background
and somehow i got connected to the head
of that boarding school and i was sort
of as a kid and as a high school guy i
knew computers i was passionate about
computers and instead listen i have
some amazing talented kids in my
boarding school
and what can you do so we sat down and i
said you know what we are going to
create a computer class computer school
for your afternoon activities for your
kids
and you did that when when did you do
that
this was about six so about like a
fourteen eleventh grade and
i recruited a couple of my friends and
we went out and we built a curriculum
and we figured out and we helped sort of
purchase some computers
from some people who donated the money
and we created for them
a class a and toilet so it was my first
entrepreneur now it's not a business
it's not a big
startup but it was creating something
out of nothing
yeah it made an impact and i did it with
some of some of my best friends so
that's entrepreneurship on day one
that's like that's high school
and then it just continues from there i
love it you know i'm thinking so much
inspiration i
i you know i'm coming from a pretty
similar background i was i think of
myself pretty entrepreneurial back in
high school especially when it comes to
you know
starting a robotics team or or you know
convincing the administration to have
the bc calculus class even though we
don't have it and i think the most
inspiring thing that is that after all
those years and after the incredible
journeys you've had
you still go back to the high school
experience which like you're saying it's
not a startup it's not a business
but it's but you created value out of
thin air and that is entrepreneurship
give me in 2s
in two words this hbs experience here at
harvard business school you know one of
the
top top places in the world for for
entrepreneurship and business
what what are those two years like
a life changing oh
changing so i've been in the panu before
i had a small company in israel
successful got acquired
but it was small scale and
the move to hps into the u.s
opened your eyes opened my eyes as an
israeli i'm talking about 97 98
to a much broader world a much bigger
way of thinking about things
and hps does it for you it basically
shifts your mind from thinking
in your own narrow okay the last thing
that i heard was
life changing you come in and you you're
no longer in your own cubicle
and then we froze
that's actually made the point i mean
that says i don't need to continue from
that
but really the point was hey
i came from i actually had my own
previous startup in israel
which was a smaller scale startup and
the move
to the states they moved to hbs
specifically opens your eyes
it allows you to really think about much
broader issues and much
bigger so for me that was
sort of a mega transition from coming
from the small market
to to the bigger world and to really
think about it in a different way so hbs
was amazing and then
besides that it's people you get a
chance to be
amazed i hear those two things i hear
about
first of all i hear life changing but
then i hear that it's both about you
know understanding
scale and and meeting incredible people
what is it about these two years
that make you transition from thinking
small-scale
nice startup to i'm going to go and sell
a company for 300 million dollars and
become the cso of blackberry
like what is that no what is that
transition i'm trying to understand
because obviously you know it's one of
the dreams of mine to come to get to a
place like this but but what
is it so first of all no one starts at
startups and knows that he's going to
set it for 300 million
so it's really about having the
confidence to make a difference and to
go for it
okay be ready to say i can do it despite
all of these crazy
hurdles and crazy reasons and good
reasons actually
not to do anything and the fact that you
have the confidence and and in some
respect the
the crazy mindset and the
extremely optimistic mindset to say i'm
going to do it
is it and hps helps them hbs actually as
a
as a school gives you the the network
gives you the confidence
i'm not saying it's the only way there's
many ways to get right into the bill and
i've been
that before but it definitely gave me a
great use now the second thing
my first investor my second investor my
business partner and my board members
yes so that helps okay so that's the
network side but you know to culminate
this
for anybody who doesn't get the chance
to go to a you know hbs or stanford
business school
and you know summarize what is like a
key takeaway that
you know resonated throughout throughout
your journey there that you think
ah this is a you know a lesson that that
that really resonates throughout the
throughout this experience got it okay
to to
to really get that you mean we need to
speak a bit about the experience
entrepreneurial experience that i
want through and it was actually
somewhat unique even for the silicon
valley
a if you count
from day one to day
exit let's call it it was from 2000
to 2015 16 or 15 so it's about
15 or 16 years a not a common
not a common path wow and went
to 9
well i should say from the dot-com
bubble bust in
2000 911 and then later the financial
crisis
took three mega mega crisis
which caused changes caused pivots uh
and still at the end resulted in
actually a very
very successful company but
it wasn't without the star and it wasn't
without tremendous tremendous amount
so if there's one key lesson
there's a few but one key lesson is and
that's something you don't not
necessarily at hbs
many places in life is if you're not in
the game you can't win
okay if you're not in the game you can't
win i love it figure out
how do you stay in the game despite
everything despite whatever is thrown at
you you need to figure out
the game and then you need to figure out
how to change and and adapt
as the game and then the landscape
change so don't get stuck you continue
to start you'll be outside but if you're
in the game
and if you're flexible enough to to
adjust
and pivot if you don't get panic when
the crisis are at you
but actually you seize the opportunity
that they provide
and you're ready for the long term
you'll get them
i love it okay so changing the
landscapes you finish hbs
talk about you you move on to to create
ad hoc
right ad hoc and ending up
in blackberry take me through this
journey so you start a company all of a
sudden you're transitioning you're in
security and
you get to join this great company and
that previously was a pioneer in mobile
and you were just telling me that
you know that what a lot of people don't
know is that there is a lot more to
blackberry than just mobile phones it's
actually you know i transitioned into a
software company
and actually dealing with also a lot of
automobiles
right so the the
blackboard is an amazing story by itself
and we can probably speak about
the side note there but it's a company
that
was at its peak right and it was at the
head of mobile and was leading the board
within mobile devices
and frankly missed the boat in when when
apple came in with smartphones
and as a result collapsed and stayed in
the field mainly because it
had a tremendous amount of money but did
not figure out the people
until a the current ceo came which is
way before i joined and decided okay
let's pivot this company to become a
software user
this is john chen right that's john chen
and jonathan did a great job in really
rescuing the business because the weight
was
going outside a a big part of what he
did is was acquisition he figured out
that he needs to bring in
talent and assets uh in order to make a
transition of this nature so it's the
technologies the customers the people
and that's where there was a big match
with what we brought in we were a
company that was dealing with
communication
with government contracts with the
security with finance
financial services et cetera all of the
things that actually blackboard is
looking for
and that's how the emerge came in and we
basically now
from within it's a different story it's
the different story because now you are
part of the team and i was in the
executive moment trying to figure out
how to take this new vision which is not
easy
and transitioned this company from a
mobile device with all of these assets
another a company at a time called good
technologies and a bunch of smaller
point companies
and get all of these entities together
to speak together and really provide
that
and that's what what that was one of my
tasks as a cso is to figure out and put
some direction around now one of the
things that was fascinating is one of
these assets
was a company called qnx which was
around
a security for cars
and they provide software that really
provides that and in the world of
security
automated cars and everything that we
are seeing in this
in in this market a blackberry actually
has a plate
and has a big plate and another one of
the key points of the water put down
but still it's a company in focus and
blackpool is
still it still needs to be proven to
prove that it can take that next step
guy you know these are these are things
that you really hear about you know
in university and case studies companies
that are coming they're market leaders
and you know all of a sudden they lose
their foot their their footing and they
have to figure out how to
you know either you know how to stay in
the game and you
got to play the chiefs chief strategy
officer
during that time of learning how to stay
in the game and thinking about how to
make these acquisitions
how what are some of the challenges
you're that you're addressing here
are there different you know cultural
challenges or different you know
adversities that people don't know where
we're headed like because people i'm
guessing are looking at you and saying
hey you're the chief strategy officer
what's our strategy
right you're outlining what is the
strategy of blackberry to stay in the
game
so it's actually quite fascinating that
startup life and turn around
life and in blackboard it was yeah are
actually
surprisingly similar and
you wouldn't be thinking about turning
around a billion dollar business
and starting a young company with zero
funding
is the same but there's a lot a lot of
similarities in it
one you need to figure out your story if
you need to figure out your message and
it's a in the turnaround it's a new
message
you need to keep focus it's not easy to
keep focus
okay even in a startup you can lose
focus very quickly
in a billion dollar business you can
lose focus even faster
of course how do you craft your message
how do you focus your business how do
you get your technologies and your
people
aligned the alignment of the people all
of the stakeholders now
in the startup it's small in a billion
dollar business it's many more now just
for context about how many people
are in the company around this time how
many are we talking here
5 000 and it's a public company so it's
not just
the employees it's customers it's the
partners and it's the investors
and you're turning around the strategy
for a company of five thousand employees
it's not just about the company it's
about remaining
maintaining alignment and and now hey
credit goes to john he's the ceo
but i get to talk to the chief strategy
officer now so john thank you very much
but i
i'm learning from you at this moment so
you're you're representing the executive
team
uh but that was a very fascinating
process and and again the similarities
with the startup
startup life were fascinating and that's
what that's what the key message
in thinking about tony lands is exactly
how to do that and how to deal with such
crisis
i love it okay so guy two successful uh
two successful endeavors
an executive in a public company at
harvard business school you probably
achieved every entrepreneur's dream talk
to me a little bit about venture capital
miasmic ventures
wha wha wha how why why venture capital
why now
what is yours why why now yeah sure
first of all it's not venture capital
okay okay
okay so what a you know it's a different
phase in my life now
i've done three startups the business
startups not including the
non-business startups and
what i'm still fascinated with
fascinated by
is is that early stage foundation and
incubations of businesses
okay that's because of what drives me
because that's the time where you can
shape you can direct
you can really figure out and create
something that is completely new
so that's what i do right now i really
walk with very
early stage entrepreneurs sometimes it
could be a professor
that is has some ideas and wants to
figure out how to
commercialize it to some class and
another case would be a
an executive that wants to get out and
figure out where to go sometimes it's
already an existing team that may have
some initial funding and wants to figure
out how to take the next step
and i joined them i joined them in some
capacity typically it's a bit of an
investment and a advisory and or board
position
but it's a very executive position
meaning i spend a lot of time i walk i
try to really make sure that they don't
make my mistakes
let them create their own mistakes but
don't make my mistakes and learn from
from that experience and what i
at the end i'm looking for is number one
is amazing
that's for me the the number one
criteria in every
every one of these decisions and and
endeavors
and obviously it needs to be a
fascinating market
the field right you want to be to be in
the field you better enjoy the freedom
right i'm always looking for friends
that have an impact
uh and have some social impact i'm i've
been working in public safety i've been
working in
security i've been working in healthcare
education
it's areas where you can actually feel
and sense the impact of what
you're creating and also
sectors that attract certain type of
people
and i'm not talking about necessarily
just the founders but the entire system
we had amazing guys we have people who
were ex-military
ex-fire fire people fire fighters
people came from emergency management of
counties
uh people that were really living the
mission and that's
the passion in the mission is is a very
crucial part
very very cool so you're saying you know
working with entrepreneurs
and working with them you know as a sort
of
almost joining their team but you know
when we started the conversation the
first thing you mentioned was that you
know when you're an entrepreneurs you're
guided by emotions and this
urge to do something that doesn't exist
this you know a lot of people say that
entrepreneurs have to be crazy
so it must be frustrating sometimes when
you're working with entrepreneurs you've
got you've made the same mistakes
they're about to make
you know they're going to make this
mistake but you know entrepreneurs are
you know
like you know guided by emotions
sometimes and i'm sure that sometimes
they don't listen
sometimes they need to make that mistake
is that frustrating to you or or do you
say okay i'm going to let them make this
mistake
so you know what i have three kids
one of them is now uh
21 years old he has his own startup yeah
so you know when you raise kids
you go through the same thing right you
you see what they do
you try to give them the best advice and
wisdom
and hopefully most of the time they
listen sometimes they don't listen
hopefully most of the time you're
correct but sometimes you're not correct
as well
so it's a matter of really the team and
the people that can walk
and to find ones that can have a mutual
respect
okay but also remember something really
important at the end it's
they'll start okay it's not you
okay as if you are joining in this case
it's me if i'm joining and i'm
supporting them
i love it i love it and you know i'm
learning so much through our work
together in j ventures and
and just i think that you know your
passion for helping entrepreneurs just
shines through this
and and i look forward to working
together much more and i had a wonderful
chat with your son the other day and i
was just so impressed and so taken back
and that it was really doing incredible
things and now i understand you know
the mentorship that he gets but guy
before we leave i have to ask for three
words
that you would use to describe yourself
got it okay you gave me a few minutes
heads up on this one but he was speaking
throughout so i didn't have too much
time
yeah when i tell you when i tell you
that you have 19 minutes to prepare it's
actually a lie because we have to you
have to answer me for these 19 minutes
uh so i would say one is passion
okay uh passion in whatever you do okay
and enjoy whatever you do number two
is persistency okay and
you know i spoke about it just be there
be there and play the game
and family is obviously your own
immediate family but
family is also the team that you create
and build in your stuff
and the ecosystem you build around it
and if you treat them as a family
thank you very very much thank you for
the time thank you for the inspiration
and and i'll see you around in our
monthly meetings
michael thank you very much take care